positivity i think it encompasses
a lot of other traits of course like
your typical resilience and whatnot but
i think unless you have a positive
attitude
then it's going to be difficult for you
to succeed it's about flipping like a
negative situation and turning it into
positive i think that's so important so
having that mindset is really going to
help you
being professional of course also having
some personality and sense of humor
i think marrying those two i think it's
always good to have
have that personality because i think
clients really liking it it does make
you stand apart
i've always worked in a really male
dominated environment
um so strangely i kind of feel used to
it
and it's really bad because
it shouldn't be as male dominated as it
is and i would love to empower
other women because i think that women
have so much
especially in a boardroom having a
obviously a vertical market so market
specialism
i think is key so when i first started i
had something called lean and six sigma
which is a process improvement
and the more and more i spoke to people
about it i pulled my leads
it was that really good market
intelligence being like fervent whether
you know just
persistently speaking to people
basically and getting that market
information
and then sending them the ideal
candidates